طبعا هذه صور تردنا من العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس للمواجهات
والتظاهرات بالطبع توقعات بمئات الالاف
سيشاركوا في هذه التظاهرات
للاحتجاج على نظام التقاعد الذي اقراته
الحكومه الفرنسيه وايضا بمناسبه عيد
العمال الذي يصادف في الاول من مايو اذا
مزيد من الحشود
والمتظاهرين في شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس وفي مدن اخرى يعني كنا شاهدنا
التظاهرات ومواجهات في تلوز وفي نانت
وغيرها من المدن الفرنسيه
الى باريس معي من هناك لمزيد لمزيد من
المتابعه مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا حسين
جديد المشهد التظاهرات والاحتجاجات وابرز
مشاهداتك في هذه الاوقات
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع حسين لنا عوده
اليه في سياق النشرات والتغطيات المقبله
اذا هذه المشاهد
للتظاهرات والمواجهات يعني تسجل بعض
المواجهات بين قوات الشرطه وبين المحتجين
في عدد من شوارع العاصمه باريس وايضا في
عدد اخر من المدن الفرنسيه
المتظاهرون يريدون من الحكومه الفرنسيه
التراجع عن مشروع
قانون التقاعد الذي اقرته الحكومه
الفرنسيه
ولكن حتى الساعه على وجود لاي مؤشرات على
ان الحكومه الفرنسيه ستتراجع
عن هذا القانون اذا توقعات
بمئات الاف المتظاهرين في
المدن الفرنسيه احتجاجا على قانون التقاعد
تبع بعض المتظاهرين يحرقون
بعض الاشياء في الشوارع الا ندري ما هي
ربما يعني هذه الدراجه
ولكن لا ندري لمن هذه الدرجه
ونشاهد شرطه مكافحه الشغب
تتابع هذا الموضوع بالطبع وتسجل بعض
المواجهات بين
الجانبين هذه قنابل مسيله للدموع بين
الطرفين ترمى الان
في هذه المواجهات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
[تصفيق]
والمتظاهرين طبع توقعات بان تعرف هذه
المواجهات
مع
تواصل وصول
الحشود من المتظاهرين لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات